[Music]
in double losses news Oh submitted by I
love David oh thank you this has been a
while since anybody said that crack my
fingers oh I honestly don't even control
you the only time that I changed a
submitted by name is whenever it says in
my name cuz I feel weird then why didn't
you change it for David because David
does not mean wait why won't you let
people say that they love you because I
read it and I'm like thank you now let's
change it that's [ __ ] up but that
doesn't make it to the public
yeah you should let those stance with it
you can feel it yeah it already
you also do terrible donations every day
exactly a court-ordered oh sorry
what's going on with you in that word I
can't say bulk order properly okay I
said properly properly you [ __ ] kill
word goals going on just tell it on my
own
poor poor words for words a court a
court orders two identical twin brothers
to pay child support for the same kid a
[ __ ] yeah about the court order and a
court orders too you know so that [ __ ]
[ __ ] mail for a second I'm good you
know what's really hard to say okay
Google
I had the to heart okay good in the
morning when I wake up cuz that's when I
set my alarm to just say hey Google
instead that stupid son of a [ __ ] can't
recognize it but it'll recognize this
hey go go it'll recognize that now do
what about when you have the music on
loud and then you're like hey Alexa she
can't hear
so that's what I figured up I'll have
the TV on and I want Alexi to do
something it won't work because the TV
is too loud so Alexa Alexa oh you know
what's really funny there's this one
time when we both streaming video games
and the Xbox Kinect you can order it to
do two things just like an Alexa or
whatever right so when people send in
donations they have like a
text-to-speech whenever they send in a
donation of robotic voice would read out
what their message says and Muslim
messages are like hey David here's five
bucks right and I just reads it out and
then the streamers like okay thank you
but people start sending text messages
and say hey Kinect turn off and then the
game turns off in their stream master
trolling that's really good what can the
Lex undies Google home things do I feel
like I'm left all your lights music
we're gonna get that for sure I have a
temperature oh it's funny you could ask
for the weather you could ask like hey I
mean like Titanic can I go set the
homicide yeah if you know you have meth
oh dude sometimes that come home in it
it's telling Nicky a story and she's
like answering questions and it's taking
her through it like a choose your own
adventure and I'm like your [ __ ]
nerves man the [ __ ] like don't worry
Nicky one of these days we're gonna
leave like this Steve it's not what you
think
yeah oh my god I swear to god I'm just a
robot and then you finally catch them
and the [ __ ] Alexis like you never
treated her right Steve I wanna hear
Alexa talk dirty to [ __ ] Nicky that's
gonna be hilarious I'm gonna get in that
video that was going viral where the
little kid was like a play fired oh yeah
sorry
reading looks like porn names oh yeah
well action anal gaping yeah in my
apartment there's only in order for me
to turn on the lights I have to go all
the way to the other side
oh no
here hold on a second so you know where
does she have to live like that so if
it's at night and it's pitch black I
can't see [ __ ] so I have to somehow
rummage my way to that [ __ ] wall only
see the other side of the apartment so
they kind of they kind of [ __ ] up I
don't understand why they did that
because you literally can't see [ __ ] at
night it's like pitch black Austin I
just hook it up to alexa or they could
just turn it on with my voice instead of
me [ __ ] tripping over do you what's
the command it's just a selector turn on
the living room I don't know we don't
use it for our lights at home here have
smart [ __ ] I don't know could be oh
it's the best you say Alexa turn on all
the lights and it'll gonna need that one
yeah do you have some kind of special
thing with your life so you could either
get the the light bulbs or get or you
could just be the socket that's all we
have we have the socket but I recently
changed my Wi-Fi thing and then I had to
change it for the thing and then it
disconnected from my Apple kit thing so
I can't use it um Apple home thing so
I'm like [ __ ] so first world problems
here whoa I just needed to control one
light so I can see at night that's it
and it's great that's dope all right so
this story here are these twin brothers
they were ordered to pay child support
to a child whose paternity could not be
established because one of the twin
boilers would refuse to express
obviously the one right the one who
refuses it I don't know I mean they both
like both of them don't give up who the
real dad is so because they know [ __ ] of
ratso they'd rather just pay both yeah
that's weird
if I'll do that no they were trying to
do with this loophole thing like well
you can't in child support you don't
know who it is and then so the judge
couldn't even order like a DNA test
either because they're identical twins
so they have very similar goodnight the
judge is like nah [ __ ] I could make
hook yeah exactly that's what he did
so now this nine year old girl is having
him she got such shitty [ __ ] daddy no
but then I thought what sobriety as
brothers though because what they were
doing is that they would impersonate
each other so they could [ __ ] each
other's girlfriends yeah like what are
you talking about that is
what porno is is yeah sharing a girl
took place in Brazil so does that mean
it's technically rape I guess she's an
imposter sex right Gina and she sees the
person and she wants to have sex with
him and she's having sex with him
willfully isn't that not rape oh no what
about knowing who it is though do you
ever really know anyone ordered to have
both of these brothers names on the
girl's birth certificate oh okay
so since night neither of them wanted to
admit who the father neither I like that
one
okay so I understand now because if it
was me if I was a bird that didn't bang
her I'd be pissed I throw my brother and
the bus immediately like I'm not paying
for [ __ ] maybe they don't know who came
who came first yeah I feel like dumped
in her well I also dumpty idubbbz in her
- I dubbed in her in January I don't
know where their energy on you area
first why did this they dumped it in
what would it be what is he cook what's
the colloquial term jack you laid it
created calculated you laid it in see
Jesus later with her as well force it I
laid with both of them men should not
lay with another man I should just talk
to my children like that not be so
[ __ ] dope yeah oh god it's cool like
that oh [ __ ] come in up did you not
greet your father once you came through
the door [ __ ] up bring your song what
it is cold outside
oh speaking of twins though there was
this other story that went viral like a
whole bunch of media was reporting it
were those 20 year olds Bangladeshi
woman gave birth to twins 26 days after
giving birth to her child
what how's that even possible it turns
out she had two uterus this is your
right
Wow no it's uteruses um yes so they
didn't because she lived like in a rural
area they didn't know how many babies
she was pregnant with so after she
delivered the first one they were like
cool I had my baby a month later I
didn't know she was still [ __ ] they
didn't do an ultrasound no but she
didn't notice she was so bad maybe she
was like I guess I'm a big way yeah
right yeah so she delivered naturally
for that first kid before the twins she
had to do a c-section I heard about that
[ __ ] though were the big ladies they're
pregnant and they don't know just
speakers already big lady we had that
Marvel chick who had abs and she's like
we didn't hear she had ABS she was
[ __ ] no she was like showing like a
little bit she looked like she was
bloated from like a full meal she was
she wouldn't know she was full girl she
knew she was she look she kept showing
pictures of her progress in the
pregnancy and I'm like you look the same
she's the future bro no baby come show
on that and it was his lady no she was
she was quite a large lady
and she had a lot of and she gave birth
to the kid in the toilet and she had no
idea she was pregnant
yeah she thought she was taking a huge
dump and then she's like I guess I ate a
whole chicken earlier because I watch
that show too some of them did think
that they were taking a dump because it
I guess there's pressure I'm like your
[ __ ] of their lives though yeah mm-hmm
this is interesting I didn't eat that
yeah what the [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]